Straight to the capital of Taiwan, now, Taipei,
where the results of the presidential and parliamentary
elections are imminently known.
Helen Ann Smith,
our correspondent, is there.
What can you tell us, Helen Ann?
Well, I can tell you it is just four hours
since the polls closed here in Taiwan,
and it seems that we have a winner.
You might be able to see on the screen behind me
that man in the white coat.
His name is Ho Yoi.
He is the opposition KMT candidate,
and he is conceding defeat as we speak
in this Taiwanese election.
And it means that the winner,
as has been expected,
is a man called Leichingser.
Leichingser is the current vice president of Taiwan.
He represents the DPP party here as the ruling party.
It's been in power for the last eight years.
Uh, and it is the party,
crucially here in Taiwan,
that takes the hardest line against China.
Uh, lighting to a popular figure.
Uh, he has really based his entire campaign
around this very clear message, uh,
that this vote, as he says,
has been a choice between democracy, uh,
and autocracy,
making that hard line against China, uh, a very,
very central part of his campaign.
And it is clearly resonated with votes.
Uh, here. It will be very,
very shortly that we will see him upon this podium.
This is exactly where we expect him to make his victory
declaration.
And we would hopefully have a chance.
To ask questions of him about that victory.
Remember, here in Taiwan
it is a flourishing democracy, a big,
a powerful economy.
They run their own military and so on and so forth.
But it is not officially an independent country.
Because it's big
powerful neighbour, China,
it feels it has a stake in what happens here.
It sees this province, uh.
This island as a breakaway province, uh.
And it makes consistent
uh. Threats uh.
Towards this island.
This China's actually worth saying
it's been a little quiet this week.
Perhaps interpreted as an kind of attempt not to
accidentally push voters into the hands of the DPP.
Because it is this result
P P a. Lighting to victory
that will be considered the most provoking outcome
uh. To China.
But look outside this tent.
There is a victory party underway uh. With uh.
People of Taipei, uh.
And people uh.
Are related.
We've been in and out of this 10.
Checking in with people
and people are excited,
they are motivated.
And again, so many of them telling us uh.
That it was that cross straight relations issue uh.
That really,
really motivated them.